So the final step in the [UNKNOWN] algorithm is this write result step of
our broadcast, so let's see what happens during that step. So let's say that we
have this situation where we have already issued some instructions. This one has
been dispatched and is executing. And now is the cycle when this instruction is
done and wants to broadcast its results. So what's going to happen?
So the first thing that will happen is we put the tag, in this case RS1, and
the result, in this case minus 0.29, on the bus. So it gets broadcast to
all of these structures. So as a result of the broadcast, this will reach to all
of these units. Now what we want to do is write to the register file, basically.
This is a new value for whichever register this supposed to be writing to, and
we don't have to carry that this is going to register F2, because reservation
station one matches F2, so we know that the value is going to F2.
So we're going to override the value in F2 with that. So, pretty much,
the first step is to kind of over-ride the value in the register file. So
we have changed the F2 now because of this match between the RAT and
the RS1, we know that F2 should be written with this value.
The next thing that happens is we update the register allocation table.
Basically the entry that matches our tag needs to be changed so
that it now points to the register file. We said that an empty RAT entry will be
indicative of just going to the registry instead of waiting for something, so
now we need to basically, you know, tag this in a way that makes it empty.
Usually there is a valid bit here that just says it's empty.
And the last thing we need to do, is free the reservation station.
That is the reservation station whose name matches is now marked as empty so
that it can accept our new instruction. In this case, we kind of just delete
stuff from it, but in real harbor, there will be a valid bit here that says that
this is an empty reservation station. So, this is what needs to happen.